don't say sorry when you mean to say
thank you that's what prevents a lot of
people from machi taking action I love
this day
[Music]
okay then at 7:30 I'm out the door
realized it's going to be a challenge
getting work done here with all the
people who want to meet and chat and
talk and and I love that stuff I mean I
can always easily get out and say hey I
got a good work but I'm here so I want
to maximize the time I have with people
and help push them to do greater things
where am I going here so this is my shot
when everybody's still sleeping to get
up and record videos I've got to do a
ton of videos I'm gonna see if I can
find something with this summit
background to support Daryl in this
event otherwise la background
otherwise just go back to the hotel room
because I need the film you guys need me
okay no signs anywhere yet they're still
setting up I've already been stopped
three times with different youtubers
it's gonna be chaos today I need to find
a spot to fill
okay I realize this is gonna be too
chaos too much noise too much stuff
happening around that something big good
quality video so I'm heading back to the
room quickly found out some videos for
you guys and then I gotta do the meet up
today I'm meeting up with local
entrepreneurs at his Starbucks so
[Music]
unfortunately the room doesn't have a
ton of amazing things to look at not a
ton of light let's open up some of these
blinds here but this is what this is
this is what prevents a lot of people
from creating all living in perfect
situations right that's what prevents a
lot of people from much and taking
action I don't have the perfect light
now I don't have my phone with the
perfect camera oh there's people around
me I can't do it always an excuse right
always an excuse always an excuse learn
to love I love this I love that I got a
film I don't this is litoris going onto
my head right now at the start it's like
work in the film
what kind of do I need some place that
doesn't have a crazy ton of noise that I
want to have a different background for
you guys it looks special and unique you
know something in Los Angeles but now
that I can't do it what's flipping in my
brain right now is this is awesome this
is the I'm filming the whole thing out
of my la nondescript hotel room and it's
the best flippin it that the problem is
the best because a lot of people right
now would stop a lot of people wouldn't
take that action and don't let that be
you don't let that be you when the
situation is not perfect it doesn't
matter you're gonna step up and show the
world and yourself what you're made of
so we're in the hotel room and it's
filming time okay okay check it out this
is my filling setup I love this look at
that
look at that that is the setup I need to
get the camera high enough that I can
stand up and I need to be facing the
window so that the Sun comes on my face
see look at how dark my hand is look at
that if I was feeling this way my face
to be really dark so I need to be facing
this way I'm filming this way so you can
see nice and bright and to get it up
high enough look we've got we've got the
bed and then an ottoman and then a couch
cushion and then a recycling bin flipped
upside down and then a water bottle so
that I can hold the phone the phone's
gonna sit right here up against that so
it doesn't fall down
that's the setup I have a YouTube
channel with 1.6 something million
subscribers and this is how I'm gonna be
filming today I love it I love it I'm so
pumped let's go what's that belief
nation it's Evan I believe in you when
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine all right
round wanna filming done pretty excited
about it but I had to turn off the air
conditioning because it was a loud buzz
it was coming in and so it got up what
well it was it was higher it's same 70
what is that 72 72 right now it was it
was harder than that
it was a sweat box in here it's amazing
like the seat recycling bin is still
there fill the whole thing it was
amazing listen one more thing I want to
show you guys look at this
I didn't notice Weston to my hotel here
how's this can you see this lavender
lavender balm sleep well one of the
things I've been constant looking for
ways to hack my sleep and I try to
lavender diffuser didn't really work so
I'm gonna I'm gonna try this
hopefully I remember tonight I get back
and I have the awareness to remember to
put this
on roll on to your temples or wrists
before bedtime to floss their sound
sleep I'm gonna try it I'm gonna try it
very excited to hack my sleep I'm
excited so I've got a couple hours
before doing my meet-up in LA gonna meet
up with local fans here at a Starbucks
I'm pumped and so here's my networking
strategy I'm naturally an introvert I
know that doesn't come out I know I have
to explain that every time but I am a
natural introvert I don't go up and say
hi to people and introduce myself and so
my strategy is I wear something
recognizable so this case hopefully
people see this t-shirt I probably
should have warned the believe ones it's
more recognizable and I sit in the
biggest most open room and start working
and either making videos on Instagram or
Twitter DM so like up the energy so that
people then come and introduce
themselves to me like who's that guy
well I think I've seen this YouTube
channel I'm gonna go say hi if you don't
already have some some brand recognition
guys look see that airplane coming I've
been trying to film an airplane landing
for a long time here in my room and I
always seem to just miss it so there it
is there's the airplane landing Nana
nanana nanana Nana land airplane land
nice okay so if you don't have a brand
that people would recognize yet like
people don't know you Egypt Channel
you're just getting started then have
something that's different about you so
here's an example like my shoes see
those shoes the other these are were
these wrap shoes I get asked about these
shoes a lot am i feeling okay
here right like did these little feel
like sandals shoes right you can unwrap
them here and put your foot in
you know pretty easy and then custom-fit
around your foot and there's still the
there's still the Vibram soles that I
love but anyway have something different
like maybe wearing all orange shirt
anything we're a crazy cowboy hat like
something that represents you an
expression of yourself don't be don't be
oh my god look another airplane listen
these things have not been flying over
I've been trying to catch them every 15
minutes something comes and here we are
back to back you see that airplane
anyway I feel like I feel like I'm a dog
being distracted by a squirrel squirrel
squirrel squirrel squirrel so have
something that represents you have
something somebody can talk about
whether it's a hat or t-shirt or
necklace or shoes or pants or anything
something that is different compared to
what most people are going to be wearing
sit in the middle of the biggest room
and then start just bring up the energy
with with your work with making
Instagram the yams with with sending out
tweets even if it's to somebody who
hasn't message you yet like just load up
your Instagram and start DMing people
who have followed you and you have to
have at least 20 followers right like
you guys you have give at least 20
followers so sit in the middle of the
biggest room and send an individual DM
to all of these people individually say
Susan thank you so much Susan that's
Evan thank you so much for following me
on Instagram I really really appreciate
it thank you so much to the love happy
Tuesday believe right and that just it
raises the energy for you it brings up
your self-confidence it it the first
ones might be a little awkward and you
know you know these people around me but
that's a good thing to break through and
then people start paying attention to
you not because you're loud and
obnoxious but because you have a you
have positivity and people want to be
around that and so if you have something
that either is you know represents your
brand that people will recognize or are
you kidding me look at this like the
planes are coming in fast and furious
when can we see it did I catch it yeah
there it is I got to stop this rent
because the planes are coming in fast
and furious now you're just raising the
energy level you just raise the energy
levels of people that want to come and
talk to you it's networking 101 for
introvert
it works it's what I do every single
time I go to an event and I'm gonna do
that now let's go first actually I'm
gonna I'm gonna clean all this up
because I don't want the housekeeping
staff to think I'm crazy I'm gonna be a
little respectful you know what I say
what is happening in here
[Music]
so just super quick because I'm getting
downstairs I noticed that I caught I
caught myself on my language I said I
don't want the people here thinking that
I'm crazy for having that stuff up on my
bed actually don't care people think I'm
crazy and I don't want to say that but
really it was about is about respect I
don't want people I don't want to
disrespect the space that I'm in and so
pay attention pay attention to the words
that you use pay attention to what you
call yourself attention to what comes
after I am or I think because you don't
let yourself down the words that you
speak come into action and so just hit
me I'm limiting myself you got to catch
up
okay so this is the main area is the
lobby I'm gonna probably find this where
everybody's going up to the event I'm so
I'm gonna probably sit in one of these
spots here and do my work so I can meet
people okay strategy worked meant a
whole bunch of entrepreneurs had a whole
bunch of conversations this is the
downside of filming I'm so in in the
zone with these entrepreneurs that I
don't I don't I don't film it I don't
say hey can we make some b-roll I don't
film the conversations so that's that
sucks for you guys watching so I
apologize but I sweat a lot I sweat a
lot I got so into it helping people out
getting fired up pushing people to do
more believe in themselves more that now
I need to have a shower so that I can
get to my meet up and not be a stink
bomb so I have a quick shower and then
head out to meet the fans LA believe
nation at Starbucks here we go
feeling good feeling liked feeling
refreshed one of the things I was think
about in the shower is
happen in the conversation don't don't
say sorry when when you mean to say
thank you when you're meeting somebody
and they're giving you their time and
their advice a lot of times to say sorry
for taking up your time and what that
does is make you feel less than
it puts you as lower than them in what
you want to say is thank you thank you
I'm grateful so never say sorry when you
want to show gratitude does it make
anybody feel good
less than a day all right time to head
to Starbucks believe they Chanel a
meet-up so I'm out by the airport not a
lot that's close to here I picked the
Starbucks that had some outdoor seating
and hopefully some indoor seating I just
realized it's a 41 minute walk from
where I am and I could hop an uber and
get there but I think I'm gonna take in
a little bit of LA we're out the airport
walk there and do some Instagram
deeanne's catch-up with people I just
like hitting the city on foot as much as
possible la is a big city
but we're gonna attack it we have some
fun
it is hot holy cow la it is hot I just
got out of the shower and now I feel
like I need another shower and I'm only
halfway there
to the Starbucks it's the best I'm not
gonna hop it over it's the best this is
the best the heat is the best this chain
link fence community that I'm walking
through is the best it's the best it's
the best it's the best
so while I am sweating my face off here
in LA walking down these streets I'm
doing Instagram DMS I am feeling a new
kind of special right now yelling into
my phone I'm feeling the fire I love
helping entrepreneurs it's what I do and
screaming on the streets of LA just
feels right
right now following the flow you got to
follow your flow five minutes away five
minutes away I love this day there it is
up ahead Starbucks coffee very exciting
hold on now
we have a Starbucks here and a Starbucks
well like I get it that Starbucks is
there cuz the Starbucks there and the
Starbucks here which one is it let me
check my map is that one but that's
hopefully not too confusing for people
all right this is it we made it we made
it we made it Starbucks
oh ho I recognize these people
so meetup is done I didn't film anything
because I was I always just spend my
time with the entrepreneurs but we got a
local entrepreneur here tell us about
your channel your content alright I just
wanna let you know that every day in
this car i watch Evan Carmichael in
traffic and what's really important
about that is instead of having road
rage we're all about learning and
growing and educating ourselves on how
to become better entrepreneurs so he's
been my mentor for the last I'd say
three years at least and helping me
build my business spy game studios.com
go visit it we're gonna go from good to
great and even further thank you very
much we had a great time at Starbucks
ahead of what like twenty-something
people pretty good amount show up
yeah a good couple hours so my 41 minute
walk was awesome here and now I'm
getting a free ride back to my hotel
there's no such thing as a free ride oh
alright we're entertaining this audience
got it there you go there's a value all
right let's go
two buddies about to do a live stream
here but look at the look at that sexy
banner okay back in my room it is 9:30
had an amazing night lots of
entrepreneurs met some new people had
some fun I got a plate that's all that's
left of the food so I'm eating super
healthy tonight broccoli and zucchini
and tomatoes it's starting to wind down
I feel sad on one hand that I can't take
you guys in with me behind all the
conversations but when I go to these
kinds of events I'm I'm all in on the
convos and helping and I'm not spending
time kind of taking out my phone
I just don't think about it and you know
so I want to make sure I'm focused on
the person bringing them as much value
and that that doesn't always happen when
there's a camera on them getting into we
had some rough conversations pushing
people pretty hard and getting them to
be vulnerable and open up when there's a
camera on them was not up is not always
easy to do so I apologize to you guys
for that hopefully there's enough still
in today's video that you got some value
from tomorrow we're gonna be doing day
one of the actual conference speaking I
don't think I'm on tomorrow I don't know
the check but a full day packed lineup
so I'm going to run because I haven't
run yet today so right on the spot for
half an hour do some stretching and
catch up on some work and then call it a
night if you guys want to see what
brought me here why I'm here my first
day leaving me now all of that check out
the video right next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there